foreign
governments and politicians get it wrong
during covid in relying on quote the
science to justify policy and
specifically within that it's the sort
of the use of Science in in politics
that I think we we want to sort of lean
into that Ben what are you what are you
thinking
um
yeah I mean I think there are lots of
governments that got lots of things
wrong I'm not sure that's why uh that
they you know excessive
um excessive Reliance on expert opinion
I mean I think that
you know one distinction I guess that
hasn't really been made that's maybe
useful to is even beyond the point about
facts and values there's
um you know having expertise on the
facts doesn't necessarily mean that
you're great at figuring out what
follows for those facts uh and
you know sometimes there are issues that
are simple enough that somebody you know
with legitimate expertise could explain
their reasoning you could say well that
doesn't really make sense right you know
that the you know I'll take your word
your word for it on the premise right
you know but that doesn't really make
sense so an example from very early in
the pandemic was the point when all the
public health authorities were saying
you shouldn't wear masks uh that's
actually going to be worse if you wear a
mask that they uh that you'll mess it up
you know you've you fools you can't do
it right you know and uh and and you're
actually more likely you know get
covered and if you if you looked at the
documents like uh CDC or who on this
um the stated reasons didn't really make
that much sense it was like oh well you
know uh people will be Reckless because
they'll think they're safe it's like all
right that's an argument to get seat
belts you know that's uh you know so so
I think there are cases like that but
overall I mean I don't
um I don't know maybe like Julie to have
a different perspective on this based on
someone what he said earlier you know
maybe Ellenwood but like I think
um
I think by and large you know the the
things that uh governments did most
seriously wrong you know I I you know I
don't think can particularly be laid on
the uh the doorstep of like you know
paying too much attention to
epidemiologists I think often it was
kind of the other way around right
I mean we don't agree with that I think
you know the point was that we're just
following the science was a smoke screen
they you know they people did that to to
avoid having to justify themselves
politically but they they weren't in
many countries in in the US with Trump
as president and with our
um uh joke of a government here I mean
they just have to just they weren't
actually basing their policy on on the
best scientific advice I think that
often they they were ignoring it so it
was using it as a smoke screen
effectively
um also the other thing is I mean it's a
good example of how people use this kind
of conveniently one of the ways in which
they kind of claimed to be following the
science which was most misguided was
they were claiming to follow the science
around behavioral psychology and
Behavioral Science right so like you
were saying how you know oh if people
wear Master actually become riskier and
and they were saying if we can't do
lockdowns because there's only so long
people will tolerate lockdowns if we go
too early everyone will break it et
cetera Etc and that that was again it
was it was very very sloppy because
first of all this whole Behavioral
Science field is far too young to have
any sort of like strong conclusions from
it you know what we know about how
people behave oh yeah no one knew how
people were behave in a global pandemic
they just didn't have the data right you
can you can only base your conclusions
on the basis of
um relevant past experience and there
wasn't relevant by past experience so it
would always have been overconfident
anyway it also turns out in the case of
the UK government they invented things
that weren't even part of the science so
the the behavioral impact team whatever
they're called
um the advise the government never came
up with the phrase I think behavioral
fatigue or something there's some kind
of like uh fatigue phrase they used and
the government is saying you know we
can't
um bring in these lockdowns because
there's this thing called whatever it is
fatigue and people will retire of it the
scientists didn't even come up with that
it wasn't it wasn't a scientific phrase
so there was a lot of just hiding behind
the signs and claiming to be following
it so I think I agree the problem was
they didn't
um listen enough to the science and and
base their bait not follow it but base
their policy sufficiently on the science
rather they just used it as a way of
like claiming that they they didn't have
to take any political responsibility I
mean I wonder I wonder how you you what
you think in that case about the fact
that obviously it's a global pandemic
right everybody had
different responses so famously in
Europe of course there was Sweden
so how does how does Sweden fit into
this perhaps they're like more
apparently laissez-faire approach was
maybe arguably the right one in that
case because they went well we follow
the science there isn't much science so
we what do you think well I think but I
think they were following I said they
thought they were following their
science their Chief Scientific Advisor
when justifying what's going on was was
appealing to evidence for saying why
this was the best policy so I mean it
really just reinforces the point that in
areas like this you know you talk about
data points and and how you join them in
this case we had quite a lot of data
points there was no
obvious uncontroversial way of joining
them to give us a theory of of what the
best action would be in the pandemic
surely in this case it
a graph's never going to tell you what
to do right
agreement really I think it's just
nonsense audio that they were following
sites I assumed it was like a legal move
almost it was kind of a way of saying
like oh if I screw this up blame him
don't blame us like just transparently
um
but I mean how could it have been
otherwise there's so many
you know normative questions that had to
go into a balance of reasons right about
you know uh how bad it is if so if some
people die how bad is it if people miss
out on education you know how how sort
of risk-averse you know how bad is
anxiety like it's a it's a balance of
reasons and for my money you know they
should have been much more explicit
about explicit about what those uh
reasons were and how they were weighing
them and then people might have been
felt a bit more reassured so I mean
obviously trust was a big part of this
and there is just this General theme of
like if you say oh you know the science
backs this there's just this implicit
trust that happens right so oh yeah so
is there shouldn't that be so
it was it was loaded into the question
that there's been a you know a retreat
of trust and Authority
um
anti-vaxxers and things
and I suppose
let's not say I've got sympathy let's
say this
um I think
um some people are becoming a bit more
aware recently that let's say knowledge
is situated right the the expertise
comes from a particular position a
perspective often a social position and
when people don't see their own you know
backgrounds represented and the people
you know doing the science and telling
them what to do they're rightly
suspicious of it and you know it's
probably not as explicit as them
thinking oh I can't see what the
background assumptions are that they're
using to you know come up with these
policies so I can't be reassured that my
values are being represented but you
know that that that makes some good
sense of what's going on I and it's
caused lots of communities to turn away
from science you know there's a certain
thread of feminist philosophy of science
that just rejects it which is awful
right because science has got all of the
resources and all of the you know all of
the money and the the big telescopes and
things
um so we shouldn't turn away from it we
should use it but I think it would be
very helpful as far as trust and science
goes if the people using the microscopes
and whatnot were more diverse so that
people felt like their values went into
this balance of reasons I'm I have to
ask in that case do you do you two think
that
the who is doing the Science Matters as
much if not more in that case than the
person who generally is the the face of
it right some policy person some legal
person some somebody else is usually the
person who uses the science it's not the
scientists who get carted out on the
whole right like yeah I mean I guess I
would say that the
um I mean look I'm all in favor of
diversity among people who are you know
actually men in the uh you know the the
microscopes uh that's a good social
value and so sure yes absolutely but I I
guess I I guess I have to say like at
least especially going back to the
context of covert you know thinking
about that
uh I'm actually a bit you know what do
you think about the breakdown trust in
science I'm actually much more concerned
about the public face people than the
people behind the microscopes I I kind
of think that people behind the you know
mostly metaphorical might you know not
always microscopes in this case like
they kind of did the best they could
right you know like they they actually
did a reasonably good job and you know
look we we got
um
I I think uh had you know had
figure things out I think all things
considered remarkably quickly I think
the things you can point to that you
know that epidemiologists got wrong
initially think its surfaces matter more
than they did stuff like that I think
that was corrected and like light speed
in the great greater speed of things
right you know we certainly got vaccines
shockingly quickly right you know people
with the microscopes they're they're
good right they're fine you know people
with the people behind microphones I'm
much more concerned with because I think
they did a lot of things actually that
were kind of own goals that
unnecessarily undermined the public
credibility of science so uh the mask
thing that I mentioned earlier is one
example
I mean another
um I I also think just times when it
just seemed blatantly political you know
the the sort of um the use of it that it
was just very obvious that people were
sort of leaning on their expertise but
that you know that they were that it was
you could see from space that there were
political considerations that were
dictating and you know how they're
saying all of these things I think you
know I think unnecessarily again I don't
think you can really blame the people
with the microscopes but I think all
these things people behind microphones
were doing did on did contribute heavily
to undermining The credibility of you
know health science at like a time you
know that's kind of the worst time to do
it because you know you need to convince
everybody to get vaccinated and all of
that yeah I think sometimes people are a
bit sort of um sloppy about thinking
what exactly is it that people are not
trusting I think sometimes people think
oh people don't trust science they think
that science is is bogus and I don't I
don't think I don't have the data points
for this but I I don't think that's the
main issue I think the main issue people
have is what the science is being used
for because if you think about it a lot
of things that people are worried about
assume degrees of competence that
scientists do not have right these
scientists cannot put these little
Nanobots into your vaccines which will
make you zombies following the
government that is incredible trust in
the power of science it's incredible
distrust in the power of authorities and
the users of science right and I think a
lot of it's like that I like the
vaccination again why would a lot of
communities worried about vaccination
again they thought technically speaking
the government were incredible able to
do remarkable things like you know
um
sterilize African-American communities
Etc right so huge trust in the power of
science but not in the people using it
and then you ask well why did they have
that you know well you know Western
governments haven't experimented on um
afro-americ yeah yes they have I mean
there's there's past evidence of this so
I think that sometimes people sort of
like Get they make the wrong defense
they start going about how great science
is I don't recognize that what you need
to do is you need to get people's trust
in how that science is being used and
for what purpose is and and that's not
scientific right that's that's about the
politics and the ethics and who controls
it who's driving the agenda and again
you can make lots of reasons why people
are justifiably suspicious the way
pharmaceutical companies for example
have driven uh research and driven the
promotion of certain drugs over others
with huge detrimental effects so people
are not stupid or paranoid because they
are distrustful about how science is
being used I think they're actually you
know they may they may worry about the
wrong things and the specific fix but
the general concern is spot on really
isn't it well okay so now that we're
talking about the past I think um as we
sort of approach the last section of
this debate be really interesting to
talk about
how we're meant to approach stuff in the
future to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas